on va parler du conflit entre le Hamas
et Israël qui entre dans sa 3è semaine
depuis vendredi plusieurs personnes ont
été libérées et certains ont témoigné on
va en parler ce soir avec Pierre
Martinet ancien otage d'un groupe
islamiste en Libye nous serons également
avec le grand reporter Régis le somumier
et l'ancien espion du KGB Sergey girnov
il vont réagir aux déclarations d'Elon
musk aujourd'hui qui ont fait flipper
tout le monde puisque Elon Musk évoque
il dit qu'on va tout droit vers une 3è
guerre mondiale 3ème guerre mondiale et
qu'on s'en rend pas compte c'est ce qu'
a dit Elon Musk aujourd'hui et c'est
vrai que quand Elon Musk dit quelque
chose on a tendance à le à le prendre au
sérieux on va regarder tout de suite la
première prise de parole de l'une des
des otages elle s'appelle yoseved
livwitz elle est âgée de 85 ans elle a
livré son message concernant son
enlèvement et ses conditions de
détention elle a dans un premier temps
raconté aidé de sa fille son enlèvement
regardez ils nous ont massacré au kibots
moi on m'a enlevé on m'a couché sur une
moto sur le côté des hordes se sont jeté
sur nos maisons ont frappé des gens ils
ont envoyé ils ont enlevé des gens comme
moi ils se moquaient ce soit des
vieillards ou des jeunes ensuite ils
nous ont amené à l'entrée de grotte et
quand j'étais couché sur la moto en
route j'étais couché sur le côau avec le
le corps d'un côté et la les jambes de
l'autre et on m'a
frappé alors ils m'ont pas cassé les
côtes mais ils m'ont fait très très mal
et j'ai eu beaucoup de mal à
respirer
alors puis elle a parlé de DEES
condition de de
détention
regardez on était couché sur des
matelas ils se sont bien occupé du côté
sanitaire pour qu'on leur tombe pas
surtout pas malade et donc on avait un
médecin qui venait tous les deux tro
jours voir ce qui nous arrivait ils se
sont bien comportés avec nous ils se
sont occupés de nous beaucoup de femmes
qui savent ce que c'est les problèmes
d'hygiène féminine ils se sont occupés
qu'on avait tout pour que les toilettes
soi propr c'est eux qui nettoy les
toilettes pas n en fait ils avaient peur
y ait une des maladies ils étai tout à
fait amicau avec
nous c'est qu'on entend la régie parce
que on a vu une are vidéo dans laquelle
il filme la libération des de deux
femmes et on on y voit
yochevedit serrer la main d'un
combattant j'aimerais qu'on en parle
juste après de cette vidéo là qui a
beaucoup
tourné voilà
al cette vidéo a a beaucoup tourné
ou oui bien sûr euh c'est fou cette
vidéo bah écoutez je pense que la la
question c'est le Hamas a commis des
attentats épouvantables a commis des
atrocités notamment dans les kibuts au
au nord de la bande de Gaza quand ces
combattants les ont sont montés à
l'assaut le 7 octobre aujourd'hui qu'il
y ait parmi les combattants du Hamas des
gens peut-être qui ont un peu plus
d'humanité que les autres c'est possible
c'est possible aussi que le Hamas comme
il libère ses otages montre et mett un
point d'honneur à ce que le monde sache
qu'il traite bien les otages ça c'est
aussi une une chose dans toute cette
histoire d'otage en tout cas il y a
véritablement un enjeu à la fois
militaire il y a il y a plein de choses
qui sont en cours je disais tout à
l'heure dans le le Times of Israël que
l'armée expliqué avait envoyé un message
l'armée israélienne je parle qui est
devant Gaza qui s'apprête à une
offensive terrestre et bien que l'armée
israélienne avait envoyé un message au
gouvernement en disant que qu'ils
étaient prêts et qu'ils craignaient que
l'ordre d'investir Gaza n'arrive jamais
parce que il y a cette question des
otages qu'on libère au comptegoutûte il
y a l'aide humanitaire et on sait que
les Américains ont fait une énorme
pression pour que l'aide humanitaire
puisse arriver depuis l'Égypte le
dispositif est en place maintenant ça
retarde de plus l'objectif premier des
Israéliens qui était d'éradiquer le
Hamas de la bande de Gaza et ça va
prendre évidemment beaucoup plus de
temps que prévu puisque il il y a encore
220 otages qui sont aux mains du groupe
nous ce qu'on aimerait savoir nous et
les téléspectateurs aussi parce que on
voit des otages libér on se dit mais
comment ça se passe comment comment il y
a les négociations est-ce pass savez
entre qui et qui les négociations euh
pierre peut-être vous pouvez nous dire
magist alors si vous voulez c'est le
Qatar clairement qui qui est à la
manœuvre le Qatar qui a une position
extrêmement ambigue mais le Qatar a une
position ambigue depuis de nombreuses
années il faut rappeler
qu'historiquement le Qatar s'intéresse à
la cause palestinienne et à la question
palestinienne depuis très longtemps il
l' gardé d'ailleurs un intérêt sur cette
question et il a financé pour une part
euh pour des raison humanitaire le Hamas
mais euh il faut rappeler par exemple
que en 2012 le chèqu altanim s'était
rendu à Gaza c'est un des seuls euh
comment dignitaires internationaux à
s'être rendu dans la bande de Gaza donc
il y a toujours eu un un intérêt du
Qatar pour cette zone il y a toujours eu
un rôle diplomatique du Qatar
souvenez-vous avec les talibans c'est
eux qui ont accueilli à DOA les
négociations entre les talibans et les
Américains pour en gros le retour des
talibans en Afghanistan et le Qatar se
veut d'être un des des rares pays à
pouvoir parler euh au pire aussi donc
ils ont il ils mettent un point mais bon
la réalité c'est que il y a aussi une
connivance idéologique avec une une
similitude dans l'idéologie avec celle
des Frères musulmans euh Pierre Martinet
vous avez été un ancien otage d'un
groupe islamiste en Libye euh comment ça
se passait comment ça se passeage les
les conditions alors il y a plusieurs il
y a plusieurs phases dans dans dans dans
dans cette dans dans cette prise d'otage
c'est un peu je je pense que ça doit
être un peu la même chose pour pour pour
les otages en Israël il y a d'abord la
prise d'otage en elle-même qui est
violente hein qui on a vu ce qui s'est
passé peut-être qu'il y a des otages qui
ont vu qui ont vu aussi des exactions
ils ont vu des membres de leur famille
famille tué décapité violé et donc
effectivement il y a il y a il y a cette
première phase où on est vraiment
cidération une sidération une très
grande peur j'avoue moi-même avoir eu
très très peur dès qu'ils ont tué mon
ami à côté de moi par terre allongé sur
le sur le sol dans une rue sombre de
Bazi et ensuite les premières minutes on
on se pose plein de questions est-ce
qu'on va vivre et combien de temps et
chaque jour chaque chaque minute chaque
heure chaque jour c'est un temps passer
sur sur sur sur sur eux finalement parce
qu'on on se demande après on se pose
d'autres questions c'est est-ce qu'il y
a des négociations est-ce que la France
par exemple dire est-ce qu'ils vont nous
sortir de là et cetera et cetera et là
dans ce caslà c'est encore plus
compliqué parce que c'est des otages qui
sont c'est une prise d'otage
internationale et avec la situation
qu'on connaît dans cette partie du monde
il y a aussi les pressions qui peuvent
qui peut qui peuvent s'exercer
aujourd'hui sur sur l'état d'Israël pour
ne pas comme disait régist pour ne
pas pénétré par par la terre par le sol
dans dans Gaza lancer l'opération
militaire lancer l'opération militaire
donc tout ça tout ça les otages le
doivent le le ressentir doivent le
savoir et il y a aussi surtout cette moi
ce qui m'a fait ce qui m'a fait ce que
j'ai tout de suite voulu savoir c'est
cette notion de temps qu'on qu'on perd
et et ça ça savoir quel jour on est
quelle heure quelle heure est-il quelle
heure il était ça c'est important aussi
pour sa survie et on on se dit que
chaque jour gagn on peut c'est c'est
c'est c'est un jour de c'est un jour de
gagner
al quelles sont les les les les
conditions là de détention là de ce
qu'on
sait visiblement euh on a vu la première
vidéo de de du Hamas ils étaient en
train de soigner une une une une
Américaine je crois
une dans dans une dans une sorte
d'hôpital donc il se comme disait régist
ils
sont ils se font fort de nous montrer
qu'ils sont capables d'avoir de
l'humanité et de et de comment dirais-je
et de traiter correctement les otages
qu'ils ont mais ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est ce qu'ils ont eu c'est ce qu'il
ils ont vécu c'est ce qu'ils ont subi
pendant la prise d'otage pendant
l'enlèvement et de et pendant les cette
fameuse attaque le le samedi 7 quoi
exactement réis quels ont été les
témoignages de ces ces de de dames sur
les conditions de détenstion est qu'on a
pas vu grand-chose qu'est-ce qu'elles
ont dit bah c'est c'est c'est vrai que
c'est surprenant de voir ces ces types
habillant en terroriste qui donnent à
manger qui on a l'impression que voilà
il y a un peu une manière de compenser
peut-être l'horreur de ce de ce qui a
été vécu que le Ham le Hamas je crois
pas je je crois qu'ils veulent montrer
ils veulent en fait il y a plusieurs
lectures de ce type de d'image ça
clairement c'est à destination de
l'Occident ou peut-être de l'opinion
israélienne pour montrer qu'il y a
encore un espoir que les otages
continuent à sortir je pense que
l'intérêt aussi pour pour le Hamas c'est
de retarder aussi cette fameuse
opération au sol parce que on sait que
les Israéliens perdront du monde mais le
Hamas netaniaahou a promis et une partie
une grosse partie de la population
israélienne a le le même avis même si
euh il y a il y a quand même de gros
problèmes avec netaniaahou en ce moment
c'est que euh le Hamas doit être
éradiqué ce qui a été vu ce que le
gouvernement israélien a choisi de
montrer au reporters hier euh ces 45
minutes de barbarie absolue et le Hamas
aujourd'hui euh montrant des des des
comment deux deux vieilles dames dont il
s'occupe il y a il y a une manière
peut-être aussi de compenser cette
horreur de dire non non c'est pas vrai
nous nous on on sait on traiter
correctement nos otages il y a plein
d'enjeux dans dans cette histoire en
tout cas ce qu'il faut rappeler et ce
qui est vraiment important de comprendre
c'est que c'est absolument inédit dans
la guerre entre le Hamas et Israël qui
dure depuis très longtemps depuis 2005
le le le le groupe est au pouvoir ça
toujours Israël a toujours fait des
guerres courtes et là cette fois ça
risque si l'opération au sol est lancée
d'être une guerre longue et une guerre
très très longue avec des otages c'est
nouveau avant c'était des militaires qui
étaient capturés donc qu' qu'on
échangeait là c'est des civils il y en a
220 ça risque d'être très très compliqué
j'ai une question importante à vous
poser dans dans un instant puis on va
revenir sur ce qu' a dit Elon Musk vous
le savez le patron de X donc de Twitter
de Tesla deuxè homme le plus riche du
monde il a déclaré hier je cite que nous
nous nous dirigeons tout droit vers une
3ème guerre mondiale Sergey nous en
parlera également et puis dans un
instant Michel Marie viendra nous voir
parce que vous allez voir voilà c'est un
nouveau truc les incroyables images de
cambrioleur déguisés en faux livreur qui
sévissent à Paris faux livreur Amazon ou
dé livvreou vous allez voir c'est un
truc de fou et c'est de plus en plus
courant donc faites très très attention
on va en parler dans un instant va tout
vous raconter là-dessus à tout de suite